Let me break this down for you so you can understand it better.
Me responding to a moral philosophical argument on the internet
is an example of an opinion that you don't like. Whereas providing
miners relates to actual you are breaking the toos
by posting my content by having that included in your video.
This is like the pirate software bit where somebody does something
really bad and you basically justify all of your bad under that
one person. Like this guy, this liquid Sonic guy made some up
about me. That's really up. And then and then he's like, "That's
the kind of thing that gets you banned from my social." It's
like, "Dude, okay." >> The thing that you did, therefore,
the word habit would be more appropriately fit describing what
you've done. Hope that helps. It's like, where'd it go, lolly
lover? You've won the argument. Like, that's what any normal
person would say out of this. It's like,
anyway, I think that's it for his. We've got a couple tweets
here, though, that followed it up. So, I'm going to I'm going
to open up these tweets. We'll take a look. exchanges with Dioro.
So YMS actually went at him on Twitter a little bit.
>> Oh, okay. We're reading this. >> Let's see here.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. So, I don't have this tweet right here, but
uh you want to read this or do you want me to read? >> This
guy's a total creep, by the way. He's desperately trying to slander
Rob's media as a child groomer to deflect away from his own statements.
And then, and then Oh, wait. Hold on. That was a previous tweet.
That's not the point here. He's showing Adam's showing that Rob's
media has blocked him. There happened to be a Nicholas tweet
in there. >> And so,
uh, Adam posts this says, "Look, look, he's blocked me." All
right. Nicholas responds.
>> You're smearing him as a child groomer. Laugh my >> Now,
this is something that I had to go and look through like everything
for, right? I had to go and look through We had to look through
the whole response. I've seen all of Adam's content. Now, Adam
is not calling him a groomer. That is like not at all. What Adam
is saying is you are breaking the toos
by posting my content by having that included in your video.
You are breaking the toos and you're doing something kind of
up like kind of you're you're edging close to the thing you're
accusing me of doing that like miners could be in my audience
and and like catch some of this and like I'm exposing them. So
here minors are in your audience. You do not have anything agegated.
I with my stuff have everything agegated. I don't have anything
that you can access as somebody who's under 18. It's all like
set up as best can be pos possibly done through the platforms,
right? >> And you haven't taken that step and I think it's
important you do. And then he messaged other people who are going
to react to it and said, "Hey, if you don't mind, could you censor
out my like account's name and so people can't find it through
videos that aren't 18 plus."
>> that's not smearing people as a child groomer, right?
This isn't above normal volume. This is at the normal volume,
Riyle. But it might be sounding louder, so I'll turn it down.
Oh, yeah. No, this should be way below the normal volume, but
I turned it down more. Is Nick just or a really person? Cuz that's
what I got out of the clip too. Out of that out of the clip,
too. Wait, which clips in signal? Um, let's see here. Hold on.
Okay, so I just think Where are we going from here? Yeah, sorry.
Sorry. I was >> oh, screenshotted, not clipped >> instead
of the >> the screenshots make him >> Oh, everything
you just outlined was clipped on Twitter. Oh, link it. Throw
me throw me a link in signal if you see it. But we're going to
keep going through these tweets. I just I think it's crazy that
you would accuse him of being a like accuse him of accusing Rob
of being a child groomer. Just didn't seem to happen. >> Hey
Dickers, thanks for the raid. So, we continue. We continue.
Yorio, he gets he gets caddyy with Yorio, which is funny. Okay,
so Dario plays this clip. >> Make love.
>> Dario plays this clip. Okay. >> Hey y, why are
you giving your m Oh, where are you going? >> Oh, I didn't
open the right I didn't open the right tweet. I didn't open the
right tweet. So I'm Ys. Okay. Looking forward to you watching
my video later since it's clear you haven't. Thanks. >> You
deserve more hate. >> So Nick says, "You deserve more hate."
Which seems kind of weird, right?
>> It seems kind of weird to just say you deserve more
hate. I don't know. Like I always feel if I don't like something
somebody's doing, I want to be able to say how I feel or I want
to like put my point of view out there. I don't need the echo
chain. Like I don't need people to direct more hate. Where does
that come from? Why does Nick feel like I need hundreds of people
to hate you? >> Yeah. I think >> you talk your you
got a platform. You got a voice. What the can? Why are you not
enough? What What is in your soul? >> There's maybe one
person I've ever thought that for. >> Probably a cheeseburger.
>> Jesus Christ. Um
>> There's another person you thought that >> Oh,
the only person I've ever thought that of I think that deserves
like more hate is maybe Pirate Software where it's like this
guy just doesn't get enough like anger towards him for the he
does. But like to compare Adam Yms to Pirate Software is so nuts.
They're like totally totally different people. Like Adam is this
like demir like he doesn't want to he doesn't even like it seems
like he doesn't even like arguing. Like he he maybe did it maybe
on text but like his videos like he just seems like super like
>> I don't think you have to be that type of person to
that doesn't seem like a good reason like oh why would you want
more people to hate him? He seems like such a nice deme guy.
Like >> no no I'm saying that versus Pirate Software. with
Pirate Software, he was like openly costic, openly like lies
about like denigrates people. >> He wore his arrogance
out in public. >> Like that was the one of the only people
I'm like, "No, this just needs more hate." Lots of times it's
just like it's funny to watch people be like and to make fun
of themselves, right? To to just like to show their inconsistencies.
That's just fun. I've never thought like, "Oh, I need way more
people to hate this guy >> or very many people." So I could
I could understand for Pirate Software when he blocks and
just silences and gaslights the people who are doing that. If
you see why YMS and his history, he engages with people. He posts,
he replies to everybody on Reddit. He's replying to comments
on here. It doesn't make sense why somebody who's willing to
engage with you, you're like, "Yeah, I need more people to hate
you." >> You generally have that feeling when you imagine
like you don't you can't even get your voice out there. You know
what I mean? Yeah. Not as like probably like the biggest commentary
streamer right >> and not as someone who can have a conversation
with Adam if you want to. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like
Yeah. Exactly. No, that is a good point. Like like all of those
people do just refuse to engage with criticism and then it's
like, yeah, this person needs more public pressure, but Adam's
willing to just talk to you. So like Adam's willing to just talk
it >> Yeah. You don't make any sense. >> We don't
have to Yeah, you don't have to throw hate his way. He's just
willing to talk to you and like have a My impression was a calm
conversation at the start of this. Yeah. Interesting.
>> Okay. Hey, Ymss. Why are you giving your minor audiences
a tutorial on how to find rule 34? Seems kind of
>> So, this is the new allegation that came out from Nick
and Rob, which was >> from an old >> old video where
he has like a reference to a furry message. >> Make love,
not war. Why can't Why can't they use a professional movie budget
for CG for something that's actually worthwhile? Like like Predator
Predator.
I should look some up right now. So from there we go. What? Oh,
Loki Coco asked if there's a mass reporting situation. I think
Adam said that like this stuff violated the toos. He I don't
know if it was his audience reporting. It could have easily been.
I think he said report the video for this violation. But I don't
know if it got hit for the violation that he said to report it
for. So it's also a little >> Adam also had a bit of a
cope with this one cuz he implied like the the next frame that's
going to come up in this clip that Oh, this is similar to me
just >> Yeah, it's not quite that, is it? >> It's
really not. None of these are what I wanted.
See, they put aliens in there, too. There's one with a demigorgon.
The top one has They have like weirdly human eyes. It's not bad
animation, though. Holy [__] One of these is 25 minutes
long. >> It's probably a distress signal coming from this
ship. >> I never even heard of 62 E621 before this clip.
Uh been linked E E621 by Rita before, but other than that wouldn't
know about it. >> I never heard of it and I'm also going
to do my best to never remember it.
>> So this leads us into what? September 18th. I believe
this is September 19th now where we get uh see here through the
top of this. Nicandra says, "Was the material difference between
what that and what Rob did that you didn't say to your audience
that they can check out Predator in this way?" Oh. Um, so,
so Yms says, "Uh, yeah, this is the funniest response you could
have done. Uh, this is the funniest response you could have given
because you would know that this was addressed in the video if
you'd watched it. Thanks." And Nikandra says, "This is the same
thing you accused Rob of doing." And I think it's pretty close
to the same thing. Like I think he could have just he could have
just accepted this one, right? But this is what Nick posts as
a response. >> So I didn't say what hole was >> one
of his arguments is that it's only grooming if you're mean.
So actually that's not literally the first the first argument
he gives in this clip is that it's far more explicitly detailed
by Rob than I than I do. Right. So Nick says one of his arguments
is that it's only grooming if you're mean. But he doesn't say
the first argument in the clip, which is Rob actually went into
explicit detail describing the penetration >> because he
knows what he's doing. He's looking for what he can possibly
like have a fighting chance against. So, he's going to pick something
that >> Yeah, sure. >> seems easy.
>> What hole was was being inserted by what thing? And
also, it's not in the context of let's shame this person, right?
It's not in that context. It's in the context of haha this movie
is so boring that I'm going to look up. I didn't say what hole
was was being inserted by what thing. And also it's not in the
context of let's shame this person, right? It's not in that context.
It's in the context of haha this movie is so boring that I'm
>> Whoops. I I did let that voice. >> One of his
arguments is that it's only grooming if you're mean. And then
he and then he added that clip. Well, this clip is he does say
that it's like um
also I don't think he's ever arguing that it's grooming again.
I just don't see how he's ever arguing it's grooming.
But um he is saying that like oh well you're doing it just to
shame me. Like you're doing it from a malicious place. I'm doing
like a joke. I'm having fun. You're doing it from a malicious
mean-spirited like evil place. Yeah. So what did Enchantress
follow up with? Enchantress follows up with Yeah. I saw the response
and I still have no clue how he can make this attack and pretend
like that joke was not in the same ballpark. Yeah, this I agree
with Nandros that it just seems like cope that the E621 thing
is not the same as what he's accusing Rob of doing.
>> So that's all there that's all there is there. Next
tweet.
Some other tweets by the way. I watched like 80% of this and
he didn't show a single clip of anything.
At one point, he made a point to say that he archived my stream,
but then just tells his audience his version of what I said instead
of just showing them. Well, I think the impression I got from
Adam was that he was going to do a video like basically going
after you guys, right? So, I get that he didn't show a clip of
anything. He didn't. He talked through
>> But it's like in context, it's like for a whole video.
I don't I didn't see him like misrepresent or he might have misrepresented
things cuz I think we we had some criticisms for him at the beginning.
So yeah, I guess he didn't pull clips. He was doing a stream
and probably just talking through this stuff. I would be shocked
if he does a >> Maybe he will.
>> at one point
>> of gifting 10 for two more hours on the stream. Let's
go. >> Thank you. Thank you. >> At one point uh at
one point he made a point to say he archived Wait, you just read
that?
>> Oh, I did. He archived my stream but then just tells
his audience his version of what I said instead of just showing
them why
just how about instead of you doing that tell me what did he
get >> or like yeah basically I think >> that's a
2hour video you're going to say oh he just summarized me why
not just show them did he summarize you incorrectly what are
you saying >> that is that is like the thing where he's
just done the same thing it's like you just now you've just >> responded
to his 2 hour thing with no
>> absolutely nothing. >> Technically, there is a
clip in the other tweet, but yeah, it's just funny. >> He
said, "Oh, he shows no clips in
>> But did he say anything wrong? Did he lie? Was there
Did he make a valid argument? Did he change your mind? Like,
what what did you do for 80% of this video? Probably eat. He
probably was
>> You leave the Can you leave the fat man alone? No, he's
making fun of an
>> He is
>> kind of brutal.
What a All right. Um, so from there, I don't know if we have
Oh, this is uh yesterday. Yes. Yes. One more tweet and then we're
eventually going to get into these um these Discord messages,
I believe.
So, Redditors want me want my channel banned because I think
that King Sham is cool. Requesting the full live stream where
Nicholas Yoro was announcing that he is a bigot against YMS and
then he cut it. Uh, today I had Okay, so >> wait, where
does this Why does this say channel banned? >> What do
you mean? >> Oh, maybe it's in the comments. >> Oh,
yeah, sure. Or or it could be in this. Today, I posted with a
T equals time tag the latest live stream of Nicholas Dioro. At
the moment, he is explicitly announcing that he is a king shaming
bigot. A few minutes later, he cut that part. As you can confirm
uh as you can confirm it from the comments in the video, saying
the video has cut a few hours from it. I wonder if he anyone
has kept it anywhere or if he or at least give us a clip. I'm
not going to pay his fan or his stand fee to get it. I'm of Hunter.
Why is this sub and Adam stri ending this whole conflict? I only
heard about of it because Adam responded to it and now I hate
that I even know that any of these [__] exist. The
mods were even deleting the original video by Nicholas Papaatti
because they didn't want to draw attention to it. This is different.
Nicholas Dioro explicitly announced that he's a king shaming
bigot last night. This is grounds for a channel ban. There you
go. Is it?
>> Hold on. Wait. There's no way he posts a screenshot
of this comment with minus six. Literally the whole subreddit
against this guy. And he's like, "This subreddit wants me banned.
These these people want me banned." >> Also, what is he?
I'm
okay. You cannot discriminate. You can't do hate speech against
protected classes. Your kink is not a protected class. >> Yeah,
probably not. >> You can be a bigot towards people's kinks.
This is so stupid. That's like, "Oh, I'm a I'm a bigot against
people who are obsessed with pickles."
>> you can't get me banned for that. >> That's true.
I can't tell
I can't tell who the bigger victim is. This furry who wants to
get Nicholas banned or Nicholas himself going, "This Reddit wants
me banned. There's They're all down voting this guy, but they
want me banned. Redditors want me banned." I don't know who the
bigger victim is. Uh, I tweeted this because people don't seem
to know why the YMS segments are being pulled and recut. Most
people who talked about this story did so on kick. I actually
messaged Chut about this. Lol. I had to mute like 300 terms so
far. >> Yeah, I don't blame him for taking his live streams
down, >> right? That is a business move. >> Edit
them if somebody's saying it. Yeah, it's fine. Being being careful.
See here.
>> Oh, sorry. That is the last tweet. This the last tweet
I had. I didn't follow anything else from this. So, I' I'm missing
a day. But then yesterday, Nicholas did talk about this in another
place. Let me pull my album. I've got some Discord messages and
then I believe there is a subreddit post that he was upset about.
Now, I don't know if stuff's been deleted from the subreddit.
Unfortunately, didn't catch this as it was happening. So, it
is what it is, man. But, let me pull this let me pull this album
in. Some Nicholas Discord see liquid Sonic tweet. Liquid Sonic.
Oh, Herman. Uh YouTube toos doesn't go by American free speech
laws, but the YouTube toos does ban hate speech against uh who
they list as protected classes. Kink communities is not one of
>> So this is the tweet that leads to what the Reddit post
or >> now Nicholas.
>> So important information regarding the Nicholas Dioro
and 2K to lift YMS >> Dioro released this video on his
YouTube channel covering the YMS meltdown. I was early to seeing
this upload, so I thought it would be a good idea to recommend
that Nicholas Dioro and YMS debate. Now, if I do say so myself,
this is an excellent idea. So, I decided to go on to my second
channel to give the comment a little updo to signal boost it.
But with the video loaded up whilst I'm on that account, this
comment is nowhere to be seen. I'm not sure what type of astroturfing
this is, if I am astroturf from his channel or if he is. So I
think the thing that was it Dickers I think Dickers showed that
this is probably this is probably just they have like a comment
flagging so they have to manually approve the comments that go
in the video which are still kind of you
>> kind of extremely extremely probably >> blocking
the word debate. He sure has engineered his channel in a clever
way if he has. But in either way, this is very gay and behavior.
So, I don't even know if Yms would be up for it. But Nick, you
should invite him to debate the ethics of beastiality on your
live stream. So, just now he says it that way explicitly to annoy
Nick. I know that. The ethics of beastiality.
Queen responded, "Nah, no way. Nick's scared he'll lose the beastiality
ethics debate." Uh, Perry leaked DMs with Rob's media running
from a debate with YMS. He did leak these. We have the full DMs,
actually. So, we'll take a look at those full DMs in just a second.
All right. But here we go. Here we go. Look at this. Oh, do I
have to click on these one by one? Oh, I do. Unfortunate.
Okay.
>> So, this starts out with the liquid Sonic tweet getting
posted in Nicholas's
Okay. How do we want to do this? How do we want to do the reading?
>> I don't know.
You do a page, I'll do a page. >> Okay, sounds good. So,
first off, cringe loser. Secondly, their point in debating
>> Obviously going to say their point in debating this.
There's no point in debating this, I'm guessing, cuz they've
turn they've learned from Nicholas. There's no point in talking
to people. You should just criticize them and never engage. I
mean, the idea is just funny. Like pointless debate, but content
farm potential. It kind of comes full circle when Rob says null
shouldn't have gone back and forth with YMS. Did he instantly
just assume the word debate is a channelwide ban term? Lauo,
that's what he's claiming. Why didn't he just try typing debate
on an alt instead of just posting that? Got me.
Uh I I think Dickers figured out that it was the just manually
flagged. Like all comments on the on his video are manually flagged.
>> Actually, can you just do all of them? These are this
too tiny for me no matter what you do. >> Yeah, this is
like very difficult for me to even read. Um but this is like
how it was screenshotted. Uh, why would anyone, and I mean anyone,
want to debate the ethics of beastiality on their channel? There
aren't any. Period.
Okay, that's cuz it's like a million sub YouTuber wants to come
on your channel and make a total cal out of himself. If there's
no way he can argue it, shouldn't that just be free? A million
one of the maybe the biggest movie, sorry, one of the five biggest
movie reviewers on YouTube want to come to your channel, right?
This guy's respected by every single old YouTuber. Everybody
who's been doing YouTube for more than like five, six, seven
years knows this guy, likes his videos in some respect. In my
experience, basically everybody knows this guy. And apparently
he wants to come on your channel and go, "Yeah, I think you could
[__] a dog and have it work out." Okay. And you don't
want that content. Really? Really
>> You don't want that content, but you do want to pull
up the video calling him basically associating with people who
have done significant harm or are like accused of being. You
want him associated with and dog, but you don't want to debate
him. So, you want to you want to lean into all of those allegations.
You don't mind those allegations or talking about those topics.
It's not like those topics are too taboo for you, but you don't
want to lean into any of them. You just don't want to talk with
him about it. You want to do it without anybody pushing back
on you being an Okay, sure. I guess so. That seems kind of weird.
All right. So, that's that's for the first part. So, next line.
But also, YouTube has this stupid thing where you can post a
comment. Even if it isn't held for review, it could take a couple
of hours to show up. That it's happened to me a lot. Person puts
in emu response. Less of a debate, more so just exposing arguments
for the sake of it. I mean, if people really need to be told
that, Lal, what beastiality is bad? No way. Well, I don't think
here's the thing. Adam's definitely not arguing that beastiality
is good. Nicholas is going to do Listen, we can see it already.
Okay, Nicholas is going to do I just don't think you should debate
this. I think it's weird to platform it. I think I think there's
just people have had these arguments. We don't have to have them
anymore. I've had them. I talked about it. I don't even care
anymore. That kind of thing. My view on all beastiality
debate stuff is it's shock value debate horror content where
you try to make everyone in the call sound like a animal to look
smarter in the eyes of antisocial internet. Yes, but you're like
doing the exact you're doing the same thing in the opposite direction.
Rob is just appealing to like a bunch of neoconservative
knuckle draggers who don't want to put any thought into anything.
They just want to say, "Oh, this li this liberal looking guy
is a this guy's like a dog. Let's go the and you just want to
do that and you want those people to laugh and clap like seals
for you. It's like you are literally the same thing in a different
direction. Why are you even throwing stones right now? You live
in a glass
>> He's groomed. >> That's fair. Kind of just show
the world how depraved and their their argument really is. Uh
5 years ago, I would even like attempt to defend this type of
debate stuff because fundamentally arguing positions you don't
hold is something that happens a lot in non-termally online debates.
But so many of the guys engaging in this debate style turned
out to be wild degenerates. Okay, this is I don't I don't even
know what this is. It's like, okay, I guess. Okay, maybe I see
the argument of like you don't like the optics of debating stuff
when everybody who's done the devil's advocate for this ended
up being the kind of thing they said they weren't. I And I even
understand the connecting dots thing, but I think you just keep
that to yourself to be honest with you. These people just don't
take positions on anything ever. Welcome back, Kilo. I heard
you died. Glad to see you are alive. This this brother's dead.
Brother I thought this brother died. Nick teaches them this.
Oh, sure. Yeah, it's uh But here's the thing, Kilo. Rob Hello.
Rob did take a position. Rob absolutely took a position, right?
Rob's media, his position was this guy. I'm going to I'm going
to be the the guy who fills in the dots. This guy's just like
Vosch and Destiny. He's super harmful. He's a weirdo that's probably
a danger to kids. That was his position. Like I don't think he
can even get away from that. Nick smart enough to not take a
position, right? Rob took a position anyway. Oh. Oh, right. Okay.
All these either take absurd debate positions because they think
they sound smart or they expose themselves as degenerates. I
mean, it's like 99% of people know it's bad. Yes. This is the
whole thing. It's realistically I'm just gonna The only thing
you got to argue here is why is it okay to basically like slander
Adam as being like Destiny or Vosch? Why do you get to call why
do you get to imply this guy's a video and then not talk to him?
Just seems bizarre to me. See checkmate liberal. You eat animals
and don't rap them. The room looks on in horror. Yeah, I don't
think that's that's not precisely that's not all he's doing.
Okay, that's not all he's doing here. And also, it's not even
just the vegan argument. Like, that's not even his worst argument.
So,
geez. Okay. Going to do YMS EFAB debate review stream. Don't
forget like you did with pinball. This type of sh This is the
type of [__] Bosch would pull on ironically.
I'm not trying to create another flamco. So, the ball is in his
court and how uh on how he'd like to proceed. If he wants to
keep swinging, I'll obviously respond. Wait, you don't want to
create another flamnco?
I think like flamco is already in. Why would you even compare
Adam to Flamco? Adam's had infinitely more success than like
you or most other creators, right? YMS
YMS has like one of the biggest channels on YouTube. He's got
a ton of like really highly regarded content. Uh regarded not
in the normal internet parlance regarded, but like highly actually
regarded. So, okay. I I literally don't get how he could compare
him to Flamco. Flamco is like was somebody who did like the stream
as their entry into content, right? like the people streaming
like Auggie stream. I don't know why you could compare him to
Flamco. Seems like totally
>> It just it seems like a bragging thing like, "Oh man,
I'm going to put another notch on my belt. Do I really have to
kill this guy like I did the last?" >> I think Well, I
also I also think it's like doing the tying thing, right? He
always does the tying of like, "Oh, >> the web or whatever."
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's like kind of webbing them together.
>> This guy's like Flamco. Remember Flamco, you guys? >> Flamco.
Yeah. You remember how Flamco was, right? I totally ripped flamco.
>> I don't even have to debate this guy. I could just remember
this guy I destroyed. He's like that guy and now I don't even
have to debate him. Amazing stuff. That's fair. I just want to
see you go over the EFAP debate they had over critical drinker.
But like this guy can literally loop forever. I feel like you'd
lose your mind. Uh if it's next if he crashes out again. Oh,
going over the EFAP debate. Was that like infamously bad for
Adam or something? I don't even
Well, I think someone in chat said um before that you know that
Yms is a really sensitive guy because of like the fallout that
he had with EFAP. >> Okay. Oh, is he like uh is he like
Adam friended? Adam and Adam. We had two sensitive little Adams
over here have a bit have a bad go on EAP and then they're having
fallouts with everybody. Adam was on with EAP going over that
VOD. I don't know which one you're talking about now. Uh okay,
going to the next page here. Sorry, these are are view a little
bit. Okay, Nicholas goes to the next page. Smackle just DM' me
asking if a channel I channel wideband the phrase debate Lauo.
I thought Hold on. I need to do it. >> This guy will talk
to Smaggle but not >> Wait, Nicholas? Yeah. >> Yeah.
Nicholas loves Smackle. Smackle's his Okay. Never forget it.
>> Oh, I thought Smaggle was Chud's.
>> No, Smaggle was Nick's. Then he's kind of back. It seems
like Listen, SMG's pretty funny. SMAGO. SMGO. Okay. I was at
work and my first thing isn't to check here because it's to go
directly to the source. I think I I think I kind of got it there.
Anyway, we love
>> We love Smaggle here. Why is this not popping up? Hello.
Oh, this isn't popping up. He posts two pictures of Adam's comments.
Okay.
Oh, he's posting his own comments on
He's posted. He's posting comments from his video. Obviously,
YMS got mad cow disease in the debate trenches. Is that the end?
Wait, where did all my other Wait, what? I thought I had way
more screenshots than this. Are my screenshots done right there?
Hold on.
Hold on. What am I doing with my life? Give me a second. There
are way more screenshots than that. I'm almost positive. Dude,
I threw these all in an album. The happened. Oh, that's so annoying.
Actually, I spent all this time throwing these things into an
album earlier and they >> Did you let them load? >> Yeah,
I don't know. Half of them broke. Come on, man. Yikes. Okay,
give me a second. I know. I know where I had them. I'll find
them again. Give me a sec. >> Hello, Chad. How's your day
going? >> So, Nicholas just keeps linking screenshots of
these things. Okay,
more more of these screenshots here. Nicholas, at the bottom
of this, animals are a lot like Boaxs. Primitive creatures. Kidding.
What? I swear to God, this is in order, by the way. Primitive.
An animal only has the base instincts of each to reproduce and
not dying. Animals instinctively don't want to die. That makes
them more advanced than most content creators. Lol. Then he posts
this. Oh boy.
Spangle post a conspiracy lemur clip in the same stream. Triggers
an obscure multi streamer to leaking his DMs with Rob's media.
Uh, let's see here. Why is Rob interacting with this guy Lauo?
He leaked Aiden's DMs with Nick. You think he wouldn't leak yours?
Nick responds, "I mean, it's fairly straightforward. I have no
idea why Rob would get in a call with someone defaming him as
a child rumor with no evidence. I feel like that's a given and
it and it leaking isn't a big deal. If it was YMS begging for
a debate on the stuff Rob claimed about him, sure. But they are
asking Rob if he wants to debate YMS." No, I see absolutely no
reason to keep that line of communication open after someone
just defamed you maliciously. Uh-huh. Listen, I don't have to
debate you about me defaming you maliciously cuz you in response
defamed me maliciously. Okay? And let's not let's not uh have
any more discussion on it, guys. Okay? Very important we don't
have discussion on it. Yeah. So, this is Nicholas. Yeah. If I
was in Rob's position, nothing I'd want to say to Yms would be
in the bounds of YouTube's to lol. And then Rob's media comes
in. Rob responds to Smaggle asking why someone would talk to
Perry. He said, "Barely knew who the guy was. just told him I'd
say to what I'd say to anyone publicly since he asked me a question
for his stream. I'll leak the full DMs because why not?
We get the full DMs between Rob and Perry. Hold on. Do I have
this last one right here? Okay. Full DMs between Rob and Perry.
Hi Rob. I recently covered your YMS video and the surrounding
drama on my stream. And while overall I agree with you, I wanted
to ask if you'd be interested in coming on my stream so that
I could devil's advocate some of Ymss's claims. Let me know if
you'd be interested. I don't think I'd have the time. If there's
a specific question or two you have, I might be able to quickly
answer them here. I plan on appearing on the Halfbaked podcast
to talk about the situation and release a short response video
alongside it. Uh, okay, sure. My main questions are, why didn't
you pin YMS's YouTube message? And is that uh is it the case
that as YMS claimed, he offered to talk to you? And if so, is
it true that you left him on Red? Also, as an aside, I realized
I watched your Lego Dino 2010 video a year ago when I was thinking
of buying the helicopter set from that the helicopter from that
set. It was an informative video.
Jesus. Perry really gets in the character, doesn't he? >> He
used to make Lego review videos. >> Maybe sounds like it.
>> That sounds like toy reviews.
He went from toy reviews to this.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> You know who loves
watching YouTube channels to review toys?
>> Oh, I should have said that. All right. Uh, yeah, I
left them on red. So, he continues on. Rob responds, "Yeah, I
left him on red." I don't owe him a comment pin if he's going
to spend said comment calling me a groomer 20 times. As said
in my original video at 11:13, I think it's a waste of time engaging
with him because he's not going to change his opinions. His tactic
is to bog you down with drawn up responses instead of giving
simple answers. Nick Durio leaked his DMs with Nick Durio leaked
his DMs with Adam and they were massive walls of text from Adam's
end. Also, as an uh Also, as an aside, I realized I watched your
Lego Dino 20. Oh, a thanks. surprised people still watch those
old videos. Okay, fair enough. I think it would be good content
and drama if you debated him though. It would, but it wouldn't
be a worthwhile discussion. He's too much of a spur in a bad
empanada sort of way. What >> does he understand what who
bad empanada
>> No, not at all. >> He can't >> he can't
possibly understand Adam is literally nothing. Like there's not
a single I can't think of a comparable dimension. Where's the
comparable dimension between bad empanada and Adam
That's baffling. It's absolutely
Ethan. Defend Idubbbz and Ana. I don't know. This seems so side.
>> It's just baffling. >> Let me Let me say that
he's just like bad empanada. It feels like they're signaling
to Ethan.
They've name dropped all of the things they need to for Ethan
to pick this up. >> Rob's media. Hey, Ethan. Ethan, I'm
Rob's media and I'd love to come on the H3H3 podcast. Okay. I
see how how well it's gone for so many of my friends. Can I come
on your podcast?
Hello. Have you seen my videos on denims? I've done many videos
on denims. I'm like something of a denims afficionado.
Okay. This guy, he hates denim so much that he's subbed to every
tier of her Patreon. Okay. He subbed to every tier of her fansly.
He's paid so much money to request specific custom content from
her because of how much he hates denims. >> I need to criticize
her. That's why I had to buy it. >> What if she was abusing
people? >> What if she was pushing communist propaganda
on the not the top tier, but the one right below? That's why
I needed access to that as well. >> She needed he needed
all of them. Okay.
Obviously. All right. We go beyond the Perry leaks.
Couple more couple more messages in the Discord. Oh, they see
about the clip live subreddit as well. There's some 50 comment
thing in the subreddit here.
He's not too much of a spur. He's too much of a spur in a person
Nick doesn't like sort of way. Yeah. Oh, you think it's That
could be it, too, that he's signaling to Nick more than uh anyone
else, right? >> Although, I guess it's just in DMs. It's
It's in DMs, but it's still just weird. It's like a thought process.
>> Nicholas says, "Lol, LMFA Queen was molding about the
whole Adam Rob thing and spicy. Adam won because Rob chose not
to debate the guy who's zuilic. Uh, do I even want to know what
he's saying? What an utter Oh, you don't like you don't want
to talk to this guy? Okay, that's basically calling you a groomer
for like 10 times. Lol, you lost. Where is the groomer allegation?
Can somebody find me the groomer allegation? You don't have the
Reddit screen caps? No, I don't. I have um I have the subreddit
or the thread, but I don't have the screen caps. No. Uh this
makes me seriously ponder why exactly people have more or less
stopped interacting with that entire community.
Started with Destiny. Oh, it was never this bad before the EHD
stuff. Started with Destiny on New Year's. I used to watch Queen
every once in a while, but it's literally contrarian about everything
now. I should have purged these guys way sooner from all my socials.
You mean the stream he's being that's being relitigated a thousand
times?
They don't like Rob because I like Rob.
Oh, no. I just I don't like that like the weird I didn't like
it from the what do you call it? The Prince of Egypt thing. The
Prince of Egypt claim. I was like, "Oh, this is a weird claim
to make. This is bizarre." It's a very bizarre claim. You're
talking I know you like bats. $100 on Kimmel not being renewed
when his contract is up in May 2026.
Why would I bet on that? What a terrible bet. Every other late
night host is losing their
>> networks are just don't get like literally nobody pays
for this stuff. >> Also, he tried watching Jimmy Kimmel.
He hated the show. Why would he bet on it >> I literally
couldn't I'm on Jimmy's side. I could not watch him speak. He's
like too cringe. >> He thinks that he's funnier than Jimmy
Kimmel. It's pretty funny.
>> No, but I I'm also I'm also not getting like $100 million
over like four years to do this. So, in terms of how much I get
paid, I'm infinitely funnier than Jimmy Kimmel. So,
>> what the am I doing here?
>> You're not getting paid that much money in 4 years?
>> I'm not getting paid like the $100 million. Yes. Were
you under the impression that was how much I was >> We
can talk another time. >> Okay. All right. Uh, where are
we here? I'm on to
this next screenshot, which is him linking the clipped live thread.
Here it is. The responses to on this thread are
Yeah, that might have been an insane claim to just assume Nick
blocked the word debate channelwide, but me and my gay loser
friends got blocked on Twitter, so it's actually his fault. Yeah,
I actually can blame you.
Anytime Queen and Friends chime in, it turns into something extremely
and annoying for literally no reason.
I just think it's weird to accuse this guy being a to like kind
of lay that on him for no reason. That's all. Check DMs for a
Reddit thread picture. Okay, we're almost done with the Oh, maybe
I should pull it up here. Just give me a second. Which which
picture am I on? I'm on the last row. Okay. Vargas, lol. Nick
literally instantly blocks anyone that's involved in Queen's
Twitter community. You can't really be surprised. People think
Nick deleted the comments. Edit. Nick is a coward who bans any
naysayers and then deletes deleted his embarrassing comments.
It's tap. To be fair, I've never watched Queen's stream, but
I know him from clips and mentions and I've never seen him uh
seen something that makes me want to engage with him. Yeah, Queen
is definitely abrasive, that's for sure. But if you just listen
to his reasonings behind why he feels so jaded, it kind of makes
sense. I mean, it makes sense on both sides why people don't
want to engage. I think I think it makes sense why people don't
want to engage uh both on like an emotional and emotional and
logical level with Queen. Like logically, he makes good points,
but emotionally I understand that he's like super abrasive and
why people don't want to engage. But that's really not at all
why they um
why they don't want to, right? It's not the emotional. It's not
him being rude. If he was being rude and he was a people would
totally engage with him and farm, right? Like 100%. It just wouldn't
even be a question. They would engage with him. They they would
try to farm him, but it's because he's not and he will actually
argue the points. That's why they don't want to engage. >> I'm
like having that thing where
so many people are saying something that now I have to question
it. >> What's up? >> I thatman
just like has really good solid arguments.
the same way like you and Queman always
>> we love Pisco. Pisco is my boy. So I'm thinking I kind
of don't like Pisco. I'm starting to think Queman kind of a >> Wow.
Well, listen, I can't really disconnect from the Discord when
we're sitting in the same room. Kind of loses it. I was just
going to leave, but I can't even really leave. >> No, cuz
literally at this point I haven't seen him have a debate with
somebody. I've seen him talk to you or me and but we're like
chill or whatever. So it's not like a contentious argument. We
try to really think alike.
I'm it is being built up is being just the image is put in my
head that he's
he's like that guy. >> Um Quimman doesn't usually have
debates unless he already knows like unless he's run out the
like logic tree. >> The last one I saw he got defeated
by a mute button with Briana. Woo.
>> I was just saying that uh I think Sure. I was going
to make like an actual thing which is I just think he um he argues
in a way where he's doing the framing thing. he'll just frame
it in a way that he can't possibly be wrong most of the time.
So, I've seen him like kind of beat Lonerbox in a debate, but
it's like it's sort of I don't know. I hate when people have
like a train of like a logic train where they're just going to
do something that I don't think actually solves the problem,
but it's just framed in a way where they can't be wrong. Like,
we're going to use these two definitions. Andrew Wilson is the
best at doing this. I think he's just like he's like, "Here are
the definitions I'm using. Explain where I'm wrong." And it's
like, "Well, it's obviously in your framing of the situation.
Like, there's no arguing with you at this point. You describe
Pisco in the same way? Yeah. All of the people who are pretty
good at debating or do like debate as a thing, the first thing
they do immediately is they have logic trees where they just
they make it so they're basically undefeable, right? It's like
it's like a trap that's set up. >> I'm obviously like not
being like all the way serious. I'm just like really bored of
saying, "Yeah, Quimman's got pretty solid arguments. He's good
debater." Just it's boring.
>> I'm not going to call you a good debater until I see
you have an actual debate. the last time you lost to a mute button.
>> Okay. Uh, everyone kind of does that, right? Um, I mean,
I don't I I explicitly like don't really enjoy doing that. Um,
I've done that like a few times.
It's
I
I think everybody I listed except I don't know Andrew Wilson,
but the other two people, Pisco and Quean, can think on their
feet and have an actual conversation, right? So, like that's
I have those conversations with them. That's why I would enjoy
talking to either one of them. Yeah. Like I but I think if you
were actually going to have like a if he was going to argue with
like Nicholas or somebody else, I think you would have those
like trees set up essentially. So snarking Queman. Yeah, we're
snarking Queen right now. I I said I think Queen I think I know
the reason they don't want to argue with Quman cuz they're probably
not going to look great. And
yeah, we went from there. >> Yeah, but that's why we have
to start here. If we start I will do it. I'll do it. I start
talking him. I call him a >> He looks like it's easier
to engage with. Yeah, he looks less intimidating. >> He's
got to throw a couple. He's got to throw a couple, get totally
like mogged, and then Nicholas will actually want to go and and
argue back. >> Cherry, explain how you defeat a mute button.
I can't explain how you defeat one. I can show you how you lose
to one. The video's probably on Kumman's >> That's funny.
The way you don't lose to the mute button is you just start you
start like making fun of them for even muting you, right? >> Yeah.
Yeah. And he and he did that like obvious I'm I'm jerk.
You know what? I'm done saying joking. It's Queman from this
point out it's Queman. Also it's Jtock's that debate either.
>> What did I do?
All right. We're back to these these screenshots here. Okay guys,
Adam's not asking for a combo. I've never denied a combo. But
Destiny Alog community has decided that this is a principled
issue and most important aspect of the story. Oh,
I think if Adam hasn't ever asked for a combo. Okay. Weird. Could
that possibly be true that he's not asking for a conversation
at all? It seemed like he was like kind of explicitly. >> No,
he said he reached out.
>> Multiple times to both of them privately and then under
the YouTube videos of
and in the comment sections >> reached out to Sensitive
Society and
>> What? This is Nick. That >> Oh, this is Nick.
>> Yeah. So, >> I think in that video he asked to
have a conversation with him. I could be wrong. >> All
right, fair enough. We can go back and try to find it. I just
don't remember if he specifically said I'd love to have a conversation
with Nick or something. Okay.
God,
we are just about done. I'm on the bottom row of this [__]
Oh, wait. I've got a whole bunch of uh I've cut a whole bunch
of other comments. Hold on. I didn't even finish these. I didn't
even finish these cuz we started arguing about Queen being a
Hold on. Hold on. Give me a second. Give me a second. Whoops.
So, yeah, Queen definitely abrasive, blah, blah, blah. To Queen,
people like Dior are just going 100% against their previously
stated ideals and such. It also seems like people are now avoiding
conversations that they pre would have previously have had uh
but now have a financial insensit
incentive to cease communication. I think that's probably accurate.
Maybe, Missy. Maybe. We'll see. Okay, here's the next thing.
I think you actually can blame people for just assuming I've
blocked a term as generic as debate channelwide. It's either
complete stupidity or just outward malice to just spread without
any testing. Ultimately, justification for this behavior is why
people like you have found themselves purged from all my
Um, okay. I don't think this is true. I I think this is like
finding this is this is like the pirate software bit where somebody
does something really bad and you basically justify all of your
bad [__] under that one person. like this guy, this
liquid Sonic guy made some [__] up about me. That's
reallyed up. And then and then he's like, "That's the kind of
thing that gets you banned from my socials." Like, dude, that's
not
>> All I didn't even say a lie. I said, "It is a felony
to destroy evidence of a crime." And he blocked me. >> Blocked.
Blocked. You're blocked. Anyway, so I I just think this is like
total. It's obviously not true.
He's I I don't even know why people do this. This is like weird
behavior to just go, "Oh, actually the reason I the reason I'm
like super sensitive about stuff, the reason I block all these
people is because um one person said that I did this or maybe
10 20 weird stuff. Okay, sure. If you feel justified, that's
fine. People are allowed to feel like you're being heavy-handed,
though. Explicitly so is you have block explicitly so as you
have blocked people on Twitter who haven't even said anything
to you or about you. Like your actions would line up with deleting
comments. You really can't be that shocked, can you?" Uh, it's
not a horrible argument that like, hey, you seem pretty sensorious.
I I think I would believe that you're censoring this given how
like outwardly sensorious you are in general. The pivot from
me being accused of blocking the word debate channelwide now
being minimized to deleting comments is another reason you guys
keep finding yourselves in this position. You guys, he's doing
the web thing. What's the What's the pivot? My initial comment
was about deleting comments. I never even said anything about
you automoding anything. So, it's ironic. You're saying my actions
led me to this position, but all you've done is misrepresent
anything I've said. Enjoy the wine moms. I guess Nick, I'm responding
to that the post where the actual YouTuber claims that your initial
comment is literally the pivot. Okay. So, you're Nick is like,
um, you're you're saying that like you're complaining about me
basically not engaging with anything you're saying, but you have
to understand I was engaging with that YouTube comment and not
you. >> Yes. Yeah. Yes, Nick. That is precisely what he
said. I'm I'm glad you caught up. I'm glad you caught up. That's
great. You're doing terrific. Content removed by moderator. I'm
a coward for responding to you. Lauo,
he likes debating. Why not just do that on
True. I listen I the liquid Sonic thing. Him saying that. Oh,
it appears like this happened. That's I guess weird, but
I don't know. I guess I didn't catch up to the Liquid Sonic stuff
in time to know if I would have piled on to that or not. Uh >> oh.
Uh >> oh. Quick update from not from this. This is whatever.
I like I guess it's it's like kind of okay drama. It's just like
boring that there's just no engagement from anyone anywhere.
It's just all nobody talks to anyone.
Just feels kind feels kind of boring to tell you the truth. I
kind of felt like the liquid Sonic thing was a joke, but I don't
know. Um I don't think it was a joke. I think he was pretty serious.
But it it was also I believe it was a little couched, right?
It wasn't totally just 100% like oh he did this, right? He said
it appears now. Does that help? I don't know. Let me let me listen
to the exact language. I get the impression that he was like
doing >> debate now, but with the video loaded up whilst
I'm on that account. This comment is nowhere to be seen. I'm
not sure what type of astroturfing this is. If I am astroturf
from his channel or if he is blocking the word debate. He sure
has engineered his channel in a clever way if he has. But in
either way, this is very gay and behavior. So I Oh, so he literally
says, "I don't even know how this happened or why this happened,
but if he did, this would be gay and behavior." Okay,
seems
>> Oh, they don't like speculation.
Don't speculate if you can't prove it right from this crowd.
>> Maybe. I mean, they clearly have already done that.
And yeah, so it would be fun if YMS was explosive like Dark Viper
or Nick/Robs Media would actually engage with him.
Yeah, it would just be better if it if that were the case. But
not going to lie, that doesn't seem like a big deal. Well, yeah,
it's it seems like he's he's like throwing in a jab here in a
in a like couched way. You could probably say
Oh, how would you put this? Like maybe the standard should be
better than that, but it's like I guess is where the standard
is right now. I don't know. Liquid Sonic was connecting a few
dipping dots. Yeah, it seems like he was connecting some dots.
It turns out people really hate when dots get connected against
them, right? Like when when Vargas here is saying, "Hey, uh it
seems like you're kind of a sensatorious guy, so I sort of believed
you censored some stuff." And Nicholas is like, "That's crazy.
Why would you why would you assume that?"
Okay. Well, I don't know. Seems like I was just connecting some
dots, dog. Why are people acting like he Well, people are acting
like uh YMS accused Rob's Media of being a groomer, and I still
have yet to see that substantiated in any way. Like I want to
see I actually want to see Nick watch something where he says,
"Okay, now I think Rob's calling him a groomer." Can we find
that? Hold on. Let me go see what videos he's got on his channel.
I'll just I'll literally just go search transcripts for it right
now cuz I like I just want to see how that came about. Oh, I
think it's at Dioro, right? Is his uh streaming channel. Am I
crazy? Is that Dioro? Okay, cool. He's got one one two
two of these. So, let's see where he does the comment response.
See where he does the groomer part. Think Rob's media is being
a creep and a groomer. Did my transcript load? I don't have the
word groom in here at all. Crazy. Okay, we got clickable. Let's
>> We got a We got a groomer comment in here. Rob's mistake
was like, "Oh, this was actually at a different event than the
event that I said it was at." His is like, "You're a groomer
who sends nudes to children." Um, also another great job with
your phrasing here. The word habit is doing a lot of lifting
here. >> Hold on.
Faming Rob, which is insane. So whereas providing miners with
actual links to is a thing you did. I mean he's laid out that
argument right because your audience is filled with minors that
you've been caught linking to. So did the groomer word just spring
out of thin air? Where did he say? This appears to be one of
the YouTube comments, right? I believe this is a YouTube comment.
So he says you provided who's comfortable sending nudes to minors.
Now that is that's a little bit okay. I shouldn't expect too
much from a guy who's comfortable sending nudes to minors. This
is pretty spurgey. But that's not even grooming.
Just to be clear, right, it's spraying out of Dro's fat face.
Okay. Well, yeah. I just I didn't see it. And it's weird that
people just take that argument and start saying, "Oh, yeah, you're
accusing him of being a groomer." That's like a specific thing.
>> These are people. Don't these people do hit pieces and
make videos calling people out for grooming? >> Yeah. Like
he knows what it is.
Or do or do they or do people need to go back through a lot of
their VODs and see if if any of those people were actual groomers?
Do they just use that term to go after somebody who did like
one bad
>> I don't know. >> How did How did this guy run
review?
How did he run ultimate review when he can't seem to discern
the difference between hey I think you're being irresponsible
showing miners how to find and you're grooming miners
who who's trusting this guy to run review ultimate review >> well
no one trusts him to do it right but that's just what the internet
is the incelss the people who can't get laid are the people who
decide what is and what isn't rap it's absurd it's wild wild
west on the on the internet the less you know the more in charge
you >> And nowhere is that more obvious than the omni liberal
explaining consent to people on the internet. Okay,
let's up. That's up. And maybe it's starting to change. Okay,
maybe it's starting to change. We'll see. Let's continue. I think
we're I think we're basically >> I mean, dude, Rob's mistake
was like, "Oh, this was actually at a different event than the
event that I said it was at." His is like, "You're a groomer
who sends nudes to children." Also, another great job with your
phrasing here. The word habit is doing a lot of lifting here
cuz it implies that you're talking about things I've done, not
a opinion. opinion you don't like. Um, let me break it down for
you. Let me break it down for you, Mark.
Me responding to a moral philosophical argument on the internet
is an example of an opinion you don't like. Whereas providing
nudes to a link, sorry, providing with links to actual is a thing
that you did. Therefore, the word habit would more appropriately
fit the dude. This is one of those where it's like, let me write
this down for you so you can understand it better. Me responding
to a moral philosophical argument on the internet is an example
of an opinion that you don't like. Whereas providing miners relates
to >> Oh, is this how you is this how he does it? Listen,
I do the voice, but I do the voice when I read something. I don't
just read back the exact thing they said, right? I change it.
He's just reading the exact same thing back in the soy voice.
Okay. >> The thing that you did. Therefore, the word habit
would be more appropriately fit describing what you've done.
Hope that helps. It's like way to go, lolly lover. You've won
the argument. Like that's what any normal person would say out
of this. It's like actually uh
Uh, lots of thoughts. Lots of thoughts going on. >> Yeah.
What are the thoughts? >> It's like I think what if this
wasn't what if he wasn't a furry. What if a YMS was not a furry?
What if he was just a gay guy? Okay.
Just a gay guy. Doesn't talk about being gay. Lives in like a
deeply Republican area or something. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> And like has the stuff and they're like outing him.
I'm trying to think of like I'm trying to think of if like any
of this video makes sense or is it just like is like almost the
entirety of the video behind oh he's a furry that's why he's
like really disgusting. Lol. Why did YMS spur out like that?
because this video is trying to tie him to people who have had
sex relationships with minors
and he has there's no evidence of him ever doing that and like
the closest you can get is him saying I don't think that you
should go to prison for drawn pictures like why should Adam let
somebody produce a 100,000 view video and then have follow-up
videos from other people where they have like hundreds of thousands
of views as well and he just shouldn't defend himself or I don't
know why that needs to be the thing like how Could that possibly
be the thing?
That seems a little bizarre. No. Am I crazy? Why should he have
to deal with that? I get I get that people are like, "Oh, you're
Standing it." If it was a channel with like 2,000 subs, I would
get the Stryand argument. Okay. But it's a 100,000 view video
on a channel that gets that has hundreds of thousands of subs,
right? Rob's Media. Rob's Media. Is it 100K subs? Exactly.
>> Almost 100K subs. Sorry. Almost 100K subs. And 100,000
views on the video. It's like not a tiny It's not a tiny
>> I don't know. And like this is all to
>> if you just wanted to if all you wanted to do was go,
"This guy is gross."
That's fine. But the the tie-ins to the other people who have
actually done like tangible harm just seems bizarre.
Well, sorry. It doesn't seem bizarre. Actually seems like calculated
and malicious, I should say. Right. It doesn't seem bizarre.
It seems calculated and malicious. I'm going to tie you to Vosch
and then talk about Vosch DMing miners. I'm going to tie you
to Destiny and talk about DM Destiny DMing miners. >> I
would say a better analogy is
seeing is hearing about
a person and and calling out a person who
is gay and rap people
and then
thinking every gay person rap people. >> It's just connecting
the dots. putting a spotlight on every gay person in like,
oh, there's something off here. They might run people any moment.
>> That's just connecting the dots.
>> I think there could I think there could be some way
of doing this. Like I think um if you wanted to make moral claims
about this, there's probably some like virtue ethicist argument
where you feel like actions should have a good tangible outcome
and
like Adam, there is no good tangible outcome to eating the dog.
It's just not there, right? This is like at worst you could do
a harm reduction argument but like I don't know it's tough. I'm
not a philosopher. Okay. Oh boy. All right. I think that's is
that it for all of this stuff? We could watch more of Nick's
commentary but I'm guessing it's just going to be very similar
to this. >> Uh because you mentioned in your video you're
actually sending nudes to real harming people infinitely more
than your crazy take on lollycon
my guy. I'm sorry you still look bad here. This is just quot
of destiny just joined the culture literally. Holy sh there's
nine of these. All right. At 6:15 did I even use the word bigotry
once just to be >> So again with the with the law defense
clip what is that 10 years ago? That's 10 years ago, right? >> I
think he was saying
Nicholas himself was saying he engaged in these kinds of arguments
like four or five years ago. >> That's to defend the fact
that people continuously bring it up, right? He said YMS said
that he has to do this every couple of years. People do a hit
piece on him >> and that's when he readresses it.
>> Not that he is out here joining panels and making arguments
on behalf of like what he does.
>> That's something that he said at the end of his video.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure.
>> to be honest, I
>> just mind blanked, but it's fine. Um,
>> let's see. >> You said 10 years ago and >> Oh,
yeah. Sorry. Thank you. 10 years ago was when he was debating
it. And you're saying he he only brings it up to defend, but
I don't even know if he defends the lolly stuff or if he like
talks about that more. I got the impression that he has to defend
being a furry and like some of his comments around Sufilia, but
the lolly stuff was like 10 years ago and he like he basically
gave like the most lukewarm defense which was I just don't think
you should go to jail for drawn stuff in any
>> Right.
I think he even said child drawn >> possession of it is
illegal to have in Canada. Yeah. Right.
>> And he's Canadian. >> Yep. Yeah. Yeah. So Rook
says you don't need to be a philosopher to be opposed to beiality.
You don't. That's not what I'm saying. >> I'm definitely
not a philosopher and I oppose it. >> You don't. That's
the one thing that I I don't even think anybody's actually picked
up on the correct thing to criticize from this video, which is
him basically going he did the Vosch comment and I don't know
if any of the actual commentary people picked up on it where
it's like he literally said, "Yes, I do think there are some
outcomes. There's some there's some se possible relationship
between an adult and a child where the outcomes are positive
for both the adult and the child." He did that, but except with
an adult and a child. It was an adult and a dog. Okay. >> But
that's why you don't you don't have these types of people.
I You can't not have them do it. But this is why they're bad
at doing it. This is why they're bad at being Chris Hansen. They
don't know how to be Chris Hansen.
>> They're bad knockoffs. And they get paid too much money
for doing such a job. Nothing will ever make them do better.
>> Yeah. Zero incentive to do better. Zero incentive to
engage in criticism.
Every reason to keep going and keep putting out slop. >> Yeah.
I'm trying to think of like if there's I'm trying to think of
like harmful genres that applies to on YouTube and like how they
handle that overall. What would the worst have been? Like maybe
like co probably like CO misinformation stuff would have been
like a big >> misinformation. But I would say pranks. >> Oh,
prank stuff. Sure. Because you would say the way that they put
out slop is this is like direct
this is affecting Adam in his real life, right? >> You
would say if you do a really bad hit job, hit piece on the internet
and you don't give people like the ability to make the argument
blah blah blah, you are directing like a mob at them. >> You're
putting them in a sort of harm's
>> It's not mutually beneficial. You don't get to cope
and say, "Oh, well, this person has an oaf." So the the hate
that I direct to them, it's going to be subscriptions for them
anyway. Like you don't get to decide if it's worth it for them.
They decided that for the prankers on YouTube. Some of those
people tried to give people money for the pranks that they did
on them. YouTube decided no
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like I don't think I don't think anything
here should get banned
>> No, it shouldn't get banned. But >> I'm I'm trying
to think of like how could this get worse. I think this is mostly
handled through conversation and like there will basically I
think everything like this where these guys get like views I
think eventually there will be like a market demand for people
who are explaining like why these videos are bad like >> oh
wait yes there will be a market demand but then I would say the
way that you can't review certain DMs and stuff like that right
you can't make slop content out of
um DMs
a minor or
sharing ing of DMs and like that. We know Chad Creeman got hit
with those >> Well, it's not that you can't make that stuff.
It's a grow uh like what would it be? Gratuitously stuff gets
Bob. >> They can't get monetized. >> But it's not
it's not that you can't monetize. It's like if you censor it
correctly, you could probably figure it >> Oh, okay. >> But
like it's probably that you know you go and do that with like
the Destiny [__] I'm guessing you get a lot of reports
from certain, right?
>> Or even the Bosch stuff. Like you probably get reports
from certain >> comm. And it's not to say you want to remove
every aspect of vigilante
vigilanteism on YouTube >> cuz what is that dude who who
did the the crypto stuff? He figured out the crypto stuff before
any government agency could. Right.
White guy sometimes wears suspenders. We've watched his videos.
>> Oh. Uh Coffeezilla.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Like he's good. You don't want
to channels like that. >> Yeah. Sure. So, you don't want
to kill the idea that like nobody can go after anybody on YouTube
or expose anybody on >> Sure. I'm sure a lot of people
here would not mind Coffeezilla getting bopped, though. >> Oh,
really? Is he bad? >> Am I Some people are not big fans
of Coffeezilla. Not big fans. That'll happen sometimes. All right.
I >> I mean, cuz down that same path, then you can't call
out
all of a sudden it it's too risky to call out uh someone in government.
It's too
I feel like it's a slippery slope. Sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Deciding whether someone's qualified
enough or they do a good enough job by
>> Yeah. I was just trying to think of like the I think
basically it's just one of those things that's I had already
saw this for myself. I just think it's like the market demand.
>> I think there's a market demand if essentially it's
the same argument that was uh like the destiny argument for why
co vaccines probably work is like there would be enough in there
would be a ton of incentive for Russia or China to show that
like America's COVID vaccine didn't work. Right. I think eventually
once you have people get who get big enough and do like this
kind of content I think there will be like a demand that comes
about for like if they're doing it badly enough or sloppily enough
there'll be a demand for better this happened to like Mad M uh
not Mad Max uh Mama Max Mama Max this happened to Mama Max it's
happened to Mudahar right if you're going to be like sloppy lazy
if you're going to lie if you're going to be all these bad things
it'll eventually come back and bite you in the ass because there
will be money everybody wants to watch these people get exposed
Right. You've you've got a whole audience who loves you watching
what loves watching you expose people. They're going to love
watching you get exposed. That audience, >> my guy, that
doesn't sound like a solution. That sounds like the the problem
creates less of a problem.
>> Like that's the same thing. YouTuber called out YouTuber.
>> Someone
obsessively watches a logs a
>> Mhm. And eventually someone else will come out and they'll
expose that
>> And then eventually that YouTuber that first exposed
the other one will start getting sloppy and then a new one will
come out and expose him. >> Not not necessarily getting
this hydra. Two more snakes will two more heads will come off
once we get rid of one person. >> Maybe. I think it's mostly
just not getting too like morally caught up in like a crusade
of any kind.
>> I think that's tech technically what usually happens
to people. Like Nicholas was pretty Nicholas had solid principles
for doing like good commentary, not getting sloppy, not being
an [__] not like lying about people. He had really
good guidelines for doing it. He just failed to follow his own
guidelines, right? You talked about it earlier where he was like,
"Yeah, like being, you know, sort of beholden to another creator,
not having like your own job and and needing like the money or
or chasing the money on here is like how you end up getting controlled
or how you end up like not following your principles." And I'll
never do that. I'll always keep my job because I never want to
have that happen. And now it's >> then it happened. >> Well,
it seems like now it's possible he's now doing content full time
and that we're getting like closer to well, you started kind
of disingenuously defending Ethan for a while and now with the
Willie Mack thing, you kind of like disingenuously defended him.
Now with the Rob's Media guy, you don't want to you don't want
to like admit that there are problems with some of these guys
and
>> Doesn't he still claim he's part-time?
Or maybe he is. I didn't get the impression he's parttime. He
streams like full-time now, right? He streams like four hours,
5 hours every night. >> But I feel like, haven't we gone
through this where it's
if a streamer built a following enough
and they isolate their community from the criticism that they're
receiving
then how do you even touch them? >> You don't. Yeah. I
don't know. If it's bad enough, you get to them anyway, right?
But realistically, there's probably some sweet spot where it's
not bad enough. You can't get through to people at all. >> Oh
my god. my [__] brain. I just heard the background
song and now I >> Running up that hill. >> Yeah,
running up that hill.